hi I'm Craig Alba reject nation I am
John Humphrey resignation of John
Humphrey aka and V vagina from the movie
trivia hoedown Black Lightning Black
Lightning this is a CW show now here's
what I heard and I could be very much
incorrect if that's the case go ahead
Kate on me in the comments because if I
asked you not to it'll just feel you to
do it more okay it's a CW show another
superhero want and it's supposedly its
own separate thing whereas you got like
flash and arrow and DC's legends of
tomorrow
those are all very much intertwined in
this crossover episode that we're not
really expecting again that much from
Black Lightning or it's just entirely
its own thing okay okay that's about as
much as I know about the show I know
this is one of DCs first like major
African American comic book characters
yeah you know a little Google search
goes a long way sometimes it does
doesn't it how a lot of youtubers look
like they know what they're talking
about
I revealed all their secrets a lot of
human beings talking about a while ago I
did a I did a video reaction to one of
those major crossover episodes of all
the shows from the CW home blog and I
was well I thought was a really cool
trailer and I was I was telling them
like I don't know why you guys wanted me
to do this I got to debate with these
people on Twitter saying I don't want to
do this because I don't watch the ship
yeah watch the video I'm like kind of
makes me want to watch all the shows and
I was not watching the show I was like a
month ago or something and I'm now on
season I'm almost done with season three
of arrow I finished season two a flash
so once I'm done with whatever's
available on Netflix on arrow and move
on in DC's legend to me
now goes to watch every superhero show
by the end of this you want to be like
fully caught up that way with 2018 rolls
around I can watch all of them even the
new ones like Black Lightning I'm going
to be caught up on all those ideas
you one goal I know I can get done this
year is watch more television either I
end up beating around the cushy oh you
have five that's right here like
lightnin is a savior because our streets
and our school safe o hope personified
but he was also Jeffers and peers but
someone else do it like our unbreakable
you story today me and your mother death
I love you both
he tried to keep his promise to my
mother so did he save more lives at the
principal regards Oh hasn't he ever did
it red light fascinating the streets
under 100 gain multiplies
I chose a diner history that no one
cares the anger was just all asserted
right the whole city was ready to
explode he can only barely realize for
so long the city is getting more more
dangerous every moment I'm just prepping
sleep I'm loving me
oh [ __ ]
oh wow
[Music]
hi
[Music]
oh she's got powers my mother or the
innocent innocent just want to give it
up
whoa damn facelet said to Cora
it was nice black like this and
[Music]
sometimes I can come off a little
overprotective
[Laughter]
I love it I love it that was a
delightful surprise
so cool I was such a delightful surprise
I've never even heard of this character
it's crazy
what a great trailer though yeah Rhian
trailer that pulled me in it was like 10
I wanted to keep bullshitting yeah it
find it fascinating how is uh you know
we're like the recent releases of shows
like Luke Cage and cloak and daggers
from marvel and then we got this show
you know CW is like black superhero [ __ ]
yeah you know like all these shows are
coming out now with a you know like
african-american leads damn do they have
like style in it how I thought all this
was about styling Greg they tend to take
place in areas that are not the most you
know well they're not white privilege
every day but ever but it brings like a
certain style to it it adds is like
great as well and while some of the
cinematography and stuff looks like of
course similar to other CW shows it
definitely has own distinct style of its
own and the characters look incredible
I'm really drawn to the characters in a
nutshell Gregory
yes sir during your home mark I
understand can you describe to me and
just a nutshell what the CW look is like
it's more of like the lighting in this
like the shot especially this shot they
have in two minutes 38 seconds like
that's a shot that I probably would
probably seen there over flash like you
feel like it this show in that you feel
like it's a show in that shot yeah
because this and we'll the one we just
watch before this in both of the year
yeah the gifted in this I got that sense
of all times there's some shots where
I'm like wow that looks like it's out of
a movie and then some shots are like the
TV show this had like a dork I almost
feel like I would imagine them so
necessary amped it
oh yeah totally yeah the other shows
even my arrow has a lot of dark elements
in it for sure
like deals a lot with death and and
violence being a very big subject in
that show I don't know how to put I mean
just it just feels like a much more grim
reality of trying to do I'm just really
drawn to upcam I'm like having a hard
time finding words is so cool because it
is what you get swept yellow I wasn't
expecting and I like the CW show that I
love I've known Adam watching them end
up loving them
I was just I haven't been flip taken
back by like I have don't even know this
character is but I'm really drawing it
with the character of Jefferson Pierce
I've been drawn to even we did an
unbreakable two story ideas one that one
didn't have to do with split at all as
we did it before split and I had a sword
once that I that I've told you about
which it deals with a retired former
vigilante who's trying to lead a normal
life but then is brought back in and
I've always liked stories like that yeah
and I love seeing that element here how
it's not just an origin tale of this guy
black lightning it's the value of having
to go back to that and bringing it back
so I can imagine the scenarios like
Black Lightning back to I love here oh
yeah I love that stuff it led with the
struggle in the stakes yeah and like
that was the perfect hook for me like I
had no idea what this was in fact I saw
Black Lightning and I was like is this
one of the other entrances
I like the starting point of it being a
guy who was already tried being a
vigilante but had to give it up yes he
character he cared about its family and
he had a protected family yeah and that
choice that that seemed to read from
this and it made me wonder what the
timeframe of all this is yeah because
they kind of give you this trailers kind
of the origins seems like the origin
story for the show yeah so it seems like
you know they want us to know this much
it can't be that much times worth in
this series I feel like you can just
jump into episode 1 right from that
ladder Harry just go for that I love the
reveal they had of his daughter
developing powers too that was actually
a nice surprise to me it wasn't like too
much or distracting you can tell like
she's probably in support of her father
doing the black lightning being the
vigilante
justise stuff and just the justice stuff
you know it's what I call the superhero
things that have a justice stuff doing
those things and then I'm curious to see
what her powers are like and I try to
read about it online if I know that
everybody have a comment or something
what you see in this and it does look
like it's something different or at
least you don't know that seems like
it's a rich well to have two people at a
different point in their powers now like
you know superhero stuff is a sandwich
so much that we could just kind of have
that conversation to it like again
that's where you can weave in cool like
allegorical Sofia cool character content
oh and another thing cool that
interested I'm really fascinating about
it the main character Black Lightning is
is an older dude he's not a young hero
in his 20s or something you know and
yeah cuz in the trailer started thought
this was going to be about like oh she's
going to take up the man that's what I
loved was going to yeah yeah and the
show could be all about her she's black
like that now and then it totally took
another turn and yeah he does seem like
an older guy which is cool it's kind of
refreshing the characters a father as as
opposed to what I've seen so far with
all these other shows where there's a
father character he's more of just the
concerned character all the time he's
like a copper something he's always
concerned about something yeah see he's
the actual superhero and the superhero
powers look cool the fight scenes look
awesome yeah one thing that bothers me
like when I see shows like iron fist or
even it happens quite often an arrow Act
era is still full filled with moments
that are pretty cool but even arrow has
it to where there's five scenes that
happen and they like speed up the
framerate and there's a lot of cutting
up to make it look cooler cooler edge
here and fancier to look than what the
actual choreography is yeah and the
actual some work is here you can clear
to see what's going on I didn't see like
a bunch of crazy framerate crazy cutting
editing [ __ ] going on like it looked
like some of the moves look like Buddha
looked like it hurt you know yeah
definitely and it definitely didn't look
like they were trying to cut around him
I did I didn't necessarily grow up in
like an inner-city community like how a
lot of these shows like you know cloak
and daggers and now black lightning are
showing us but there's something that
feels still more relatable about
a world like this even have someone like
me then approach to like Starling city
or central city yeah well yeah it feels
like a different town and I don't know
like another part of the the thing I
think works really well but these shows
the setting becomes a character and I
feel like you have to have kind of a
character that's challenging that dad
like I think this is a good backdrop and
it is in this trailer like harkening two
images you might see on the news yeah
yeah it's really jumping you into it and
it looks like it's going to dive
headfirst into the trouble of it all you
know and that's I think that's a great
idea
it looks like the grittiest one that CW
will probably have right now I'm excited
for this show so much I can't wait to
watch it I'm actually I'm genuinely
really excited for this by tomorrow I'm
going to be like a guy I could if I just
watch the trailer and then knit a review
on it a day later I would have had all
my thoughts and work in order of it I
was just so taken I bet I wasn't
expecting to love the trailer that I was
threatened to be like oh it looks cool
yeah they're like whoa I am out of words
right I hope I have that the same we
actually when you come out of a movie I
don't want to review this tonight yeah
I'm like crunch the numbers do she kind
of processes and how do I have a good
time hi alright well day thanks to
everyone who kept commenting saying we
gotta check this trailer out ble was
check then that was awesome that was
yeah second X to the arrowverse
apparently so so I don't happen later
have to watch a butch show who's in what
0 only if I wanted you can subscribe to
the real rejects dad John Humphrey on
Instagram and Twitter click the
notification bell here he's also a
social media manager Blum house.com you
can go check out our patreon we did a
lifestyle live-streaming at Google
hangout Google hang with a few people
few patrons today which is a total blast
every time we say we're gonna talk for
30 minutes turns to an hour in like 2007
we thought he would keep any things we
talked for a long time such cracks me
jokes we have much of exclusive person
on there just go check it out it all
goes to help support the channel so go
check it out my friends if it floats
your boat
help float
I don't know what that means